there's the proposal around it's got a
lot of interest called the universal
basic income where everybody is
guaranteed at least a certain level of
income in the society some free market
economists so like Milton Friedman
talked about a negative income tax which
in effect had the same features of
guaranteeing a certain level of income
for everybody as a base I think from a
human rights and decency standard
there's a lot of sense to the idea that
everybody in a society should be able to
meet their basic needs there's on the
other hand the sense if you give someone
to check whether they're trying not
trying working not working if there's no
effort no conditionality involved at all
maybe we're going to get a lot of people
that are absolutely doing nothing on the
backs of those who are really working so
the incentive issues are real even if
the sensitivity and decency issues are
also real I think that one way to handle
this is a little bit more rounded rather
than seeing a universal basic income as
a check and a kind of an unconditional
check that's just handed out as income I
like the idea of social democracy as its
applied in real countries in Europe in
the Netherlands and Denmark Norway
Sweden Germany the ideas everybody has
access to publicly financed health care
everybody has access to quality publicly
financed education including college
tuitions not a trillion dollars of
crushing student debt but tuitions paid
for everybody has access to not only
guaranteed vacation but paid vacation
everybody has access to quality
childcare so that moms can go to work
knowing that their kids are in a healthy
nurturing environment everybody has
access to
maternity leaves so that moms and also
paternity leave dads can stay home with
their kids for several months it's kind
of decent where you say we have all this
wonderful technology this wealth why
don't we live decently not not miserably
if people want to market income beyond
that they got to go work for it if
course they're disabled and for some
reason can't then there's added social
support but it's not cash in people's
pockets its decency it's public services
it's basic needs met I see it as
basically living decent lives in decent
societies they have a very different
spirit to them there aren't a lot of
super rich Wall Street hedge fund
misanthropes and I'll use the term
advisedly because I find a lot of people
on Wall Street don't give a damn about
anybody else except they care about
their money and I find that really weird
but you don't find that kind of idea in
northern Europe because it's really
looked down upon and people don't like
it when people are money-grubbing
they're kind of shunned
so the social ethos is different I
remember once I was running to the
airport in Oslo and I fly business class
and I'm constantly moving around and on
trips relentlessly around the world and
I ran ups and where's the business class
of lying to board and the guy looked at
me like I was crazy and he said excuse
me we're boarding the Scandinavian way
get back in line and I just thought okay
that's pretty cool actually
you know everybody's in line and let's
all get on the plane it's a social
spirit it's the idea that we like we
like wealth by the way they're not this
is not people tearing their their
clothes and living in hair shirts and
and you know not enjoying themselves
they like their vacations they like
their boats in the
stockholm archipelago they like six
weeks on their island so they they live
beautifully but they don't want
gazillions they don't they don't want to
do it at the expense of others they want
to do it as a society god if America
could just get a little of that back
rather than a president who believes in
killers and losers sick but that's what
we got and that is what's degrading
American society not just the technical
issues not just the rising inequality
but this spirit that you're a winner or
you're a loser and if you're a loser get
out of the way that's Ain Rand talking
it's ugly and we've had enough of it